[Aplausos]
para comenzar les pido que traigan a su
mente alguna situación que estés pasando
que esté ocasionando que sus vidas
carezcan de equilibrio
si le identificaron por favor levanten
su mano
gracias la palabra adaptación significa
hacer que un mecanismo funcione para lo
que no fue construido y darwin lo
describe en su teoría de selección
natural para ello vaya a fuego de nuevo
méxico nos da un increíble ejemplo de
esto hace más de mil años
allí se extendían kilómetros y
kilómetros de desierto dorado lo que le
permitía a los ratones de bolsillo
camuflarse de sus depredadores hasta que
el paisaje cambió drásticamente las
erupciones arrojaron un río de lava
cuando la roca derretida se enfrío
oscureció kilómetros dentro de ese
desierto imagínense el gran problema en
el que estaban estos ratones ahora no
sólo no podían camuflarse ahora
inclusive estaban resaltando gracias a
su color para darwin la manera en la que
nacemos va a depender de dos cosas de la
naturaleza el organismo y la naturaleza
de las condiciones de vida y en los
ratones ocurre algo que se le conoce
como mutación es un cambio en las letras
químico
que conforman los genes y los ratones
cambiaron su color aquellos ratones que
estaban en esa área y que ahora podían
camuflarse en este nuevo entorno
sobrevivían y los que no se convertían
en un bocadillo del desierto lo que este
increíble historia nos quiere decir es
que los que sobreviven son los que
logran adaptarse a su ambiente y que el
que no se adapta muere cuando me di
cuenta entonces que la adaptación es tan
importante para los animales me pregunte
qué pasa con la adaptación humana tendrá
que ver con situaciones de vida y con
recursos personales al investigar me
topé con dos conceptos que describe el
que describió el epistemólogo psicólogo
y biólogo piaget el primero de ellos la
asimilación como un sujeto se enfrenta a
un estímulo en términos de organización
actual para ello les daré un ejemplo
cuando estaba en la preparatoria no me
importaba mucho la escuela la verdad no
ponía atención tampoco entregaba las
tareas
y los proyectos cuando entré a la
universidad me estaba comportando de
esta manera pero ahora estaba teniendo
resultados verdaderamente negativos
entonces ocurre lo que se conoce como
acomodación esto ocurre cuando el sujeto
se ajusta a una situación nueva y
comencé a poner atención a entregar mis
proyectos y generalmente sentirme
verdaderamente bien con la carrera que
estoy estudiando entonces me di cuenta
la adaptación es muy importante para
nosotros y para los animales ahí fue
cuando reflexioné sobre la lección de
vida más grande que he tenido de
adaptación ocurrió un 21 de marzo del
2014 la persona con el corazón más
grande que conozco mi papá se acercó a
mí y me dijo hijita de mi vida no hay
nada que hacer el cáncer de tu mama ha
avanzado un 97 por ciento para que
entiendan el motivo de mi sorpresa no
sabíamos que mi mamá tenía cáncer lleva
con él
diez años mis papás se enteran días
antes y yo me entero en eso
pero era una realidad no había nada por
hacer y al día siguiente ya le estábamos
velando tuve la gran fortuna de poder
despedirme de ella y entre palabras más
o palabras menos una frase que siempre
quedará bastante presente en mi vida es
que le dije por mi hermanita te puedes
ir tranquila me daba cuenta que mi
hermanita era la típica hermana menor
que vemos a lo mejor en casa que pues se
le consciente mucho y no se le decía que
no y cuando esto ocurría pues habían
rabietas le expliqué el nuevo modo en el
que íbamos a estar funcionando y le dije
ya ante de las rabietas ante que me des
obedezcas van a comenzar a ver castigos
a ver límites en ese entonces yo tenía
16 años y ella tenía 6 y note que no me
estaba creyendo sólo me quedaba una cosa
por hacer de mostrarse
a la semana siguiente comenzamos a ir de
nuevo a la escuela
esto desató una gran rabieta en ella en
la que mediante gritos y llantos pedía
no ir a la escuela no ir a la escuela y
no ir a la escuela se me había
presentado la oportunidad entonces de
demostrarle que estaba hablando en serio
lo que hizo fue que subí el uniforme de
mi hermana el coche subí a mi hermana
cargando al coche
puse seguro de niños subió y comencé a
manejar en el transcurso sonaban sus
gritos sus llantos con sus manos iba
cubriendo mis ojos como se podrán
imaginar algo que suponía un riesgo en
la vida de ambas entonces para el coche
la mira y le dije estoy hablando en
serio sí para cuando lleguemos a la
escuela no te has puesto el uniforme
pues te voy a bajar en pijama
encendido en el coche y en el transcurso
la vi por el retrovisor poniéndose su
uniforme al llegar le expliqué que
estaba hablando en serio sin embargo que
tuviera la certeza y la seguridad de que
si necesitaba desahogarse con alguien o
platicar con alguien yo le iba a
escuchar pero a través de rabietas no
de esta manera me convertí en la figura
materna de la que de algún modo pues ya
mi casa carecía me encargaba de la de
lavar la ropa de limpiar mi casa también
desde la disciplina un poco de mi
hermana
y cuando entras y después entré a la
universidad
al entrar a la universidad de continuar
con estas responsabilidades que
honestamente yo misma me había
adjudicado ya era mucho más cansado mi
papá se daba cuenta y me decía por qué
no te mudas más cerca de tu universidad
y no lo hacía después de un año y medio
decidió tomarle la palabra y ahora si me
toca enfrentarme a uno de los retos más
grandes que me he tenido que enfrentar
en estos 21 años
la soledad el estar ahora lejos de mi
familia me causaba tristeza ansiedad y
una culpa bastante grande entonces
decidí comenzar a ir al psicólogo en el
proceso me di cuenta que la persona a
quien debía comenzar a cuidar
responsabilizar y disciplinar era mi
misma la verdad no fue nada fácil pero
cuando lo hice fue increíblemente
sanador la realidad es que adaptarnos no
es fácil porque constantemente nos
recuerda que van a ver las adversidades
que van a llegar nos van a tocar la
puerta y no vamos a tener quizás en ese
momento las herramientas para poder
enfrentarnos a ellos pero una parte de
una canción de calle 13 cambio mi vida
si quieres cambio verdadero pues camina
distinto no podía continuar enfrentando
me a la vida de la misma manera si yo
quería ahora tener mejores resultados
como decía anteriormente adaptarse no es
fácil pero el que se adapta puede lograr
tres cosas el que se adapta puede
equilibrar su vida el que se adapta
puede mejorar su raza como esos ratones
que sobrevivieron se siguieron
reproduciendo y pasando esos genes a
otras generaciones el que se adapta
evoluciona te quiere invitar a que la
próxima vez que te enfrentes a esa
situación que trajiste a tu mente hace
un momento recuerdes una frase de víctor
franco cuando no podemos hacer nada por
cambiar nuestra situación estamos
retados a cambiar nosotros mismos
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]